علماني جدا اظهرت تدينه لكي يتم اعتباره
شخصيه مهمه في تاريخ العرب لم يكن يملك
اسلحه دمار شامل قبل غزو بوش للعراق ولم
تكن له علاقه بالقاعده بل كان لا يؤمن
بايديولوجيهتها ولا يحب زعيمها انه الرئيس
العراقي الاسبق صدام حسين بروايه كتاب
المحقق الامريكي جورج بيرو الذي استجوبه
عقب غزو العراق قبل عقدين من الزمن سبعه
اشهر من الاستجواب ولساعات يوميا فتره
طويله كانت كفيله لتفصح لعميل مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدرالي الاميركي عما يدور في
ذهن صدام حسين
بيرو قال انه لعب على حبل الزمن بعدها اسر
صدام حسين ان همه الاكبر لم يكن الولايات
المتحده ولا اسرائيل بل كان ايران لذلك
كان يدعي انه يمتلك اسلحه دمار شامل او
كان غامضا بشانها بردع الايرانيين عن غزو
العراق
المحقق الامريكي افصح ايضا ان صدام حسين
لم يكن متفاجئا من غزو الولايات المتحده
للعراق فقد ادرك ان الحرب حتميه بحلول
اكتوبر او نوفمبر من العام 2002
بيرو تحدث ايضا مع صدام حسين عن روايته
زبيبه والملك التي صدرت سنه 2000 قائلا
انها تشبيه منه لحال الشعب العراقي والقوه
الامريكيه وصدام الملك المنقذ
المحقق الاميركي خلص الى ان احد اكبر
اخفاقات الولايات المتحده تفكيك الجيش
العراقي فالعراق الان بحاجه لرجل يضع
البلد في اولوياته وهو ما فعله صدام حسين
يقول المحقق جورج بيرو بلال البجدين
العربيه